I don't know why you're happy tonight
you want that's good I know you're proud
to be an American because it's been five
days without a massacre how about
got a hand for ourselves huh what a
shitty week right poor El Paso and
Dayton still reeling from two disasters
a mass shooting and a trump visit just
every city isn't one is asking the same
questions why why why why does this hair
look like that
[Applause]
well the president is off for a well
well-earned two-week vacation which will
be different from working how they want
you to know president will be available
at all times if there is an emergency
that needs to be made worse
he is completely we know now this
pattern that we have always seen
whenever there's a tragedy it's all
about how he's feeling right it's like
is he okay this week he after after the
massacres he attacked the media Obama
Google sherrod Brown the mayor of Dayton
Beto California sleepy Joe is the only
president who thinks consoler in chief
means you console him
and also he's a whiny little [ __ ]
but seriously mr. president don't
console us really we don't I know well
in Tet don't console us and mostly stay
out of hospitals we right I mean we have
seen what he does in these situations
like you know he threw paper towels to
hurricane victims was he doing a
hospital throw Tylenol I mean these poor
people imagine waking up from surgery
and standing over you is this grinning
gaseous blob and his scowling trophy
wife people are like [ __ ] I must have
died and went to hell
they're like I'm in the hospital I've
had enough orange jell-o
but of course you can't tell him he's
unpopular his nude press spokesman drank
the kool-aid said oh yeah Trump went to
the hospital said they treated him like
a rock star yeah our Kelly none none of
the eight patients in the El Paso
hospital would agree to meet with Trump
isn't that something they were they were
all asked would you like to meet the
president they all said El Paso
[Applause]
here's a sobering statistic gun violence
has paralyzed 535 people in this country
this year they're called the United
States Congress come on stay with me a
little faster than that now Americans up
medically they will endure school
shootings they will endure church
shootings but they draw the line at
their shopping trips to Walmart that is
too far so well the the shooter in El
Paso did it because all the things that
Trump says all the time he took to be
true like Mexico is invading is that
kind of [ __ ] he took all that to be true
but in his manifesto he wanted everybody
to know that he wasn't getting this from
Donald Trump no no no he was getting it
from lou dobbs same his truck but but
what he did do this guy this shooter he
wanted to know nothing to do with Trump
although in the manifesto Trump does get
a story by credit but it's scary the way
some of this stuff is going so
mainstream Tucker Carlson of Fox News
says white nationalism is a hoax
he gotta love Republicans global warming
is a hoax Russia that was a hoax white
nationalism is a hoax Hillary Clinton
runs a pedophile ring out of a pizza
parlor completely true that one
and Tucker's evidence that white
nationalism is a hoax he says it's
because he never met one
oh come on Tucker yes you have
[Applause]
you